you
[Music]
hi my name is reka antenna poly I did
get the honor of being mentioned
multiple times by Kristin and thanks for
that so I work in a group called foundry
99 and this is a startup accelerator
group inside Microsoft Research our
responsibility has been you know
building a team with Kristin
to push forward encryption technologies
AI technologies and how we apply privacy
in AI so private AI has been one of our
topics of interest for the past year and
a half so why why are we interested in
this it's it's quite fascinating I mean
you look at this world today and there's
there's always this there is this notion
that we want to build AI based services
and you know there are industries that
want to collaborate this internet has
created this collaboration paradigm
where everybody wants to bring data from
multiple places and then use this for
providing more innovative services such
as in in finance and health in in
manufacturing Christian presented part
of this but we look at situations where
companies are not being able to
collaborate there is you know if I look
at Finance there is anti money
laundering
right it's a big big issue where kind of
financial institutions are not able to
collaborate with each other to provide
an optimal service and this we see as
lost opportunity so we think that it's a
50 billion dollar market opportunity for
when when we can provide more
privacy-preserving
services the non barriers are pretty
obvious right there are two very very
big barriers when you think of data
sharing and collaboration and this is
privacy and security and where it
differs I'm sure you all know where it
differs is that you know privacy is when
you want to protect your customers data
but you want to be privacy aware you
don't want to intrude into into a
customer or a business's work whereas
the security is you know if you're not
able to handle the data properly that
you lose it and some other threats
happen
so where we looked at is for example one
of the ways is when consumers privacy is
violated through their health data you
know we have always seen you know we are
very right that when we present our
health data and there was this example
where recently when somebody was when a
company like 23andme is taking your
genome you know your data and then you
don't know what they're doing with the
data they could be selling it they could
sell it to your insurance company and
then you would be you would be you know
you probably end up paying more
insurance I don't know
so there is concern where a consumer is
really worried about their own health
data and how how an organization might
protect their own privacy
there is also issue when consumer data
is mishandled right now this is an
example where there were there were
issues where an app that you were using
like Strava inadvertently published a
heat map of all runs that their users
was doing this is not intended there was
no malicious intent in this but there
was just mishandling and what happened
that they ended up identifying mostly
locations across the world because there
were these military most people were
also using Strava and you know you
suddenly in the middle of it that said
you see this you know as a heat map of
people running around like hey what is
this and there was curiosity around that
sport now this was just mishandling of
the data right and whether a weather app
you know the Christian showed you are
secure whether there is a reason we
build that app because there was this
weather app that showed you that was
capturing users location data and was
now sharing this this was not the
intended use of a weather app right you
want to use a weather app because all
you want to do is get get the the
weather of the particular location that
you're in and also for example I mean
companies as big as Google are always
being challenged about the use of
location data from their users right now
but they do this because they want to
provide personalized services you know
finding a restaurant around you
finding a you know a a tater where you
could go around you now these are things
that you're querying Google about but
then they have to store this location
that belongs to you so in a sense they
can tell where you are actually going
around and this are you know then there
is the security issues where you know
there is you know companies are holding
your data per as strictly and as safely
as possible but then there are there is
malicious intent by hackers who want to
actually access the data while it's
while it's being stored in the cloud and
being able to you
you know extract the data that could
then be used for that they would use it
for malicious intent now there is
there's huge ramifications for companies
when such a breach happens right they
lose trust from their users they lose
they have financial losses that happens
because of that and you know it
eventually you know there are some
companies that have probably gone even
bankrupt because of such data breaches
happening and why why do we have to look
at through look through all of these
right like you know the new digital
revolution is about a AI and AI is data
hungry right one of these articles is
very interesting for us because it does
question the the basic premise of AI is
saying that is AI the ultimate test for
privacy it's it's a it's a kind of like
a union problem where you look at it and
say that I I need data to build AI
services but then I don't I I don't want
to access the data because if I do then
I have to take care of privacy and
security of the data how do I solve this
problem so what we see is a potential
opportunities that AI requires gathering
and storing huge amounts of data and
then there there are new collaboration
models that have to be established for
people for services to build imagine
this I mean this goes back to the the
lot of health related scenarios that
Kristin mentioned you know you want to
do better cancer prediction one of the
best way to gather
data is by asking every hospital that is
actually getting you know radiologists
are actually analyzing images to
contribute that back to a central
repository now this is nearly impossible
given the regulations and stuff that
exists today but maybe with these new
upcoming technologies we that landscape
can be changed and there could be new
data collaboration paradigms so the main
challenges that we think are like you
know there's there are data management
policies and regulations that basically
eyes off even in written Microsoft we
are eyes off and we look at office data
we tried we don't look at your data when
we come to you know providing better
services or they're there you know there
has to be a model where we trust third
parties right there's this is a common
pattern in financial services where they
establish new third parties that say
that hey I can you know Bank a and Bank
B cannot collaborate with each other so
here's my data that I will share with a
third party who is a trusted party and
then and then we hold our data commonly
you are in a you know in an in an escrow
there are these issues if you take
typical offerings in in cloud-based
services where there is there lot of
implementations of encryption
you know while data is at rest you could
encrypt all your data and store it and
rest well when you when you have to
process it you have to obviously have to
decrypt it today until we get home what
we can encryption completely into the
cloud right because that is a problem
when you decrypt the data it is
vulnerable and then you would put
barriers around it that people cannot
access the data but still it has been
decrypted and as a huge aversion to
market entry because people are just not
able like there is trouble in putting a
foot forward when you see issues such as
privacy and security so in summary what
we have learned is that regulations have
made become policies right in financial
services a huge number of policies that
restrict companies to collaborate with
each other
we have seen that
when companies like and this is between
companies large companies right there
when there is ease ease of breaking
trust when there is misuse of data it's
not only within companies it's also
between consumers and the companies
right like the example that I said you
know you you use a weather app because
you want to just get the weather but
then if that is being used to track your
location and shared with with legal
agencies you know it is the trust is
totally broken and and you always hope
that your data is being handled properly
right how many of you trust that your
financial institution is handling your
information when you apply for a loan as
best as it can you do have a trust with
them but then that trust is it broken
the instant their that your data is
breached right there were there were
instances recently of large financial
institutions storing username and
passwords in a cloud-based Dropbox file
share maybe right this is this has
happened and these are the instances
when data breaches happen right and so
you know learning from all of this we at
Microsoft have been focused on a lot of
scenarios right and and these are
examples these are examples where you
could possibly think of how this can be
applied for somebody as big as Microsoft
with office for example the our moto is
like empower every customer with new AR
by services while protecting their
privacy and data right you think of the
new services that office is building
into your platform which includes like
the PowerPoint designer it's a it's a
fantastic feature right and you know how
do we protect the customers privacy
while doing so or you could think of it
as you know as your blaze cloud
offerings where we empower our
developers to provide privacy preserving
cloud-based services you could think of
this as you know cloud-based data
sharing services where we empower we
provide as you're being a platform as a
service we empower other developers to
to build on top of that or you empower
existing product offerings and this
could be like sequel and spark and so on
where where we empower it by providing
models that leverage homomorphic
encryption to to to ensure that the data
that is used that this that these
services use are encrypted at at all
times we could also think of vertical
offerings like you know and we can
empower businesses to offer solutions
such as you know cancer prediction or
anti money laundering or know your
customer and we have seen that
homomorphic encryption applies really
well to some of these scenarios so
Kristin did talk about that and you know
one of the the reasons I brought this
back is that you know I really wanted to
share say how a company can think of
providing solutions leveraging
technologies like home morphic
encryption right
it's you know like companies have been
taught and told how to build
applications in a very common way which
is like you know you store the data
unencrypted in the cloud then you do
some processing and so on but a short
run is an open source example that you
can take a look at how this you can
change the paradigm of an of a
commercially available application where
the organization takes responsibility of
storing data only in an encrypted form
but still being able to provide the same
service that they were offering when
data was not being encrypted and so on I
mean so there are plenty of ways to
think or models to think about how
homomorphic encryption can be applied in
the real world right you could think of
doing eyes off training which means that
you know you always have data encrypted
and you do training on it you could
think of enabling really secure data
sharing where you have two parties that
we only want to share bits of data
between each other where you know the
they then this goes back to the privates
at intersection example and the kind of
secure weather example that we showed
right you could also think of it as out
so storage and compute which ties back
to the whole thing around prediction or
analytics in the cloud when data is
always encrypted or you could think of
Bill
bring multimodal datasets where you have
fed you acquire the data by federating
by using a phred iterator model across
multiple companies and so on and you
acquire the data which goes back to the
cancer prediction you acquire multiple
datasets encrypted manner and then do
some analytics or training on top of
that and yeah enjoy the bootcamp and we
are here to talk to you
[Applause]